we want to figure out how many balloons
we have here and obviously we could just
count these but now we have other ways
of thinking about it especially because
they're arranged in this nice in this
nice array this nice grid pattern here
and the reason why it's useful to not
just always have to count it but to be
able to use a little bit of
multiplication with the number of rows
and the number of columns is that you
might run into things and you will run
into things where it's very hard to
count each of the objects individually
but it's not might be a little bit
easier to count the rows and to count
the columns so for example right over
here we see that we have one two three
four rows and we have and we have 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 columns so this is a you could
view this as a 4 you could view this as
an array of objects where we have four
rows let me write that down we have four
rows and we have seven columns seven
columns and you might already remember
that we can calculate the total number
of objects by multiplying the rows times
the columns four rows times seven
columns now why does this work why do we
why does this why will this give us the
actual the actual number of objects well
we could view this we have four rows so
we have four groups of things and how
many things are in each of those in each
of those rows well the number of columns
we have seven things in each of those
four rows so for four groups of seven or
you could view it the other way around
you could view that you each column is a
group so then you have seven groups and
how many objects you have in each well
that's what the rows tell you you have
four things in each of those in each of
those columns and we already know that
both of these both of these quantities
are going to find the exact same number
the number of things that we have right
over here so these two things are
equivalent 4 times 7 is equal to 7 times
4 and there's a bunch of ways that we
can calculate either one of these we can
skip count by four we say 4 times 4 8 12
16 20 24 28 and let's see let me make
sure that's 7 so 4 times 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
so we get 28 we could just calculate
their 28 objects here and likewise we
could skip out skip count by sevens we
could go 7 7 times 2 is 14 times 3 is 21
times 4 is 28 just adding 7 every time
and so we could get 28 the other way
let's do that in that same color we
could get 28 the other way but what if
you had a situation where you didn't
know where you either didn't want to do
these techniques it would have been hard
to do these techniques or you didn't
know what 4 times 7 was off of the top
of your head which you should know at
some point in the very very near future
is there any way to break this down into
something that maybe you do know or
maybe that's a little bit easier to
compute well you could realize that 7
columns is the same thing as 5 columns
and then 2 columns so you could view 7
columns as you could view it as 5
columns so this is 5 columns right over
here plus 2 columns
plus juice in another color plus 2 plus
2 columns so that's just like saying
that 4 times 7 4 times 7 we do the 7 in
that purple color I want to stay
color-coded is the same thing as 4 4
times 5 plus 2 5 5 plus 2 and all I do
is I replace the 7 with a 5 + 2 7 has
been replaced with the 5 plus 2 now why
why is this interesting well now I can
break this up into two separate arrays
so I could say well look there's a 4
there's the array that has 4 rows and 2
columns right over here and then there's
the array that has 4 rows and 5 columns
right over here so how many objects are
in this one in the yellow one right over
here
well there's 4 times 5
four times five objects so there's four
times five objects in the yellow grid or
yellow array and how many and how many
in the in this orangish looking thing
well there's going to be 4 times 2 4
times 2 4 times 2 and if we take the sum
of the 4 times the 5 and the 4 times the
2 what are we going to get well we're
going to get the 4 times the 7 we're
going to get the 4 times the 5 plus 2 so
if we take the sum of these things and
we want to do the multiplication first
so I'll just put a parentheses around
that to emphasize that that this is
going to be the same thing as these
things as these things up here and so
you might say well I know what 4 times 5
is 4 times 5 is 20 4 times 5 is 20 4
times 2 is 8 20 plus 8 is 28 and you
might say okay Sal you know that's that
was kind of a you know I get it
4 times 7 is 28 4 times which is the
same thing as 4 times 5 plus 2 and I see
that that's the same thing as 4 times 5
2 plus 4 times 2 and actually this is
called the distributive property that 4
times 5 plus 2 is the same thing as 4
times 5 plus 4 times 2 but you know I
could just I could just do with one of
these first techniques you talked about
why is this distributive property that
you just showed me why is this useful
for computing well or doing
multiplication up problems well let me
give you a a a slightly more difficult a
slightly more difficult one let's
imagine you wanted to multiply you
wanted to multiply 6 times 6 times let's
write it as 6 times 36
make sure I don't need to write that
parenthesis 6 times 36 so how could you
do this well you could decompose 36 into
2 products or into two numbers where
it's easier to find the product of that
and 6 so for example 36 is the same
thing as 30 plus 6 so this is going to
be equal to
6 times 30 plus 6 6 times 30 plus 6 and
what's this going to be what we just saw
6 times these two things added together
first this is going to be equal to this
is going to be equal to 6 times 36 times
36 times 30 plus 6 times 6 plus 6 times
6 6 times 6 notice we distributed this 6
6 times 30 plus 6 times 6 now why is
this useful why was this useful at all
I'm going to put parentheses to
emphasize we're going to do the
multiplication first in general when you
see multiplication in addition in a row
like this or end division you wonder
your multiplication and division first
then do your addition and subtraction so
what's 6 times 30 well this is easier to
calculate 6 times 3 we know to be 18 so
6 times 30 is going to be 180 and 6
times 6 well we know that's going to be
36 so this is going to be 180 plus 36
and what's that going to be 180 plus 36
well 0 plus 6 is 6 8 plus 3 is 11 1 plus
1 is 2 so you just figure it out that 6
times 36 is equal to 216 and what we
just did what we just did with the
distributive property this is actually
going to be how you're going to multiply
all sorts of larger numbers way larger
than what we just saw so the
distributive property which hopefully
you're pretty convinced by by based on
how we broke things up is a super useful
thing as you want to compute larger and
larger numbers and you're going to find
it even more useful when you go even
further in your mathematical career